you rightly picked up on the disruptive
effect of social media but also the
technological shifts in in media and
mass media consumption my argument was
that this might be you know leading to
polarization of people like you who are
immensely successful within this middle
year also driving your book sales you
know you just just I think just talking
to you hit the top of the Amazon list
here in the UK but there is that you
know that the point that you become part
of the problem that you've put your
finger on yourself you want people to
get along together you want men and
women to sort of trade off we don't
agree entirely where these trade offs
are but you know we were here in arguing
about it and yet at the same time you
succeed most when you say something very
provocative that goes viral you think
you're sort of no I don't think that's
when I succeed most so for example one
of the one of the incidents that
propelled me to to to success let's say
in terms of public recognition in the UK
was my interview with Kathy Newman and
the reason that that propelled me to
success wasn't because I said something
provocative but because I refused under
substantial duress to say anything
provocative and so the part of the
reason that I've become popular to the
degree that I have been is that I'm
actually very good at keeping my temper
under situations that would would would
not under situations where there's
substantial reason not to let's say and
I would also say that the the good that
I've done with regards to my online
lectures far outweighs whatever harm
might be done by the fact that people
are cutting them and making provocative
titles out of them and construing this
as some sort of fundamental political
war